most of us at one point or another in
our lives have wondered who am I really
why am I me and not someone else where
was I before I was born what will happen
after I die am I the same person from
one year to the next these are very
personal questions when we take the self
to be not the thing that does the
perceiving but an aspect of this flow of
conscious experience that requires
explanation itself then I think we're
making progress
what is the real problem of
consciousness
I think it's it's this approach to
understanding Consciousness that I'm
taking and I think a lot of my
colleagues also are whether they know it
or not the real problem is in contrast
to the so-called hard problem the hard
problem of Consciousness is this problem
which seems very hard of trying to
figure out how in the world something
like conscious experience felt
experience the redness of red the
sharpness of pain
now that is generated by or is identical
to stuff happening in the world of stuff
Mata biological stuff we're made of
stuff it's complicated stuff but it's
still stuff how does that give rise to
conscious experience that's the hard
problem
now we can try and solve it head on but
no one's managed to do that yet the real
problem of Consciousness is the is it's
just saying that Consciousness exists
some philosophers even would have us
doubt that Consciousness exists we all
know what it's like to have experiences
of the world itself and they're related
in Intimate ways to the brain and the
body so can we try to explain
properties of Consciousness like what
experiences feel like why are visual
experience is different from an emotion
can we explain properties of
Consciousness in terms of the brain and
the body
and I think if we do that that's
addressing the the real problem
and
whether we eventually completely solve
the hard problem or not is still up for
grabs but let's see how far we get and
my suspicion and and belief really is
that by making progress on this real
problem then the hard problem with
eventually fade away and just dissolve
in a puff of philosophical smoke
what would an explanation of the real
problem of Consciousness look like I'm
trying to work out what sort of form
that could actually take
it's could take many forms and there are
there are many different forms they all
kind of move us away from what the
Neuroscience of Consciousness started
like which was Finding correlations
between things happening in our
experience and things happening in the
brain for example a correlation could be
your part of your brain maybe your
frontal cortex lights up when you
consciously see something but doesn't
when you don't that's a correlation it's
useful to know
but it's not the whole story it's not we
it doesn't give us a sense of
satisfaction and we all know
intuitively and in other areas that
correlations are not the same thing as
explanations or causations like I think
there's there's things like the
historical price of cheese in Wisconsin
correlates with a divorce rate in France
I think which is a fun fact but it
doesn't mean anything have you seen the
correlation between I think it's the
number of movies that Nick Cage was in
in that particular year and the number
of people who drown in their own
swimming pool
well maybe there is a causal link there
I mean that seems potentially
okay to the road swimming pool to escape
the new Nick Cage movie it's yeah I mean
it seems unlikely but you never know but
no this is the point that correlations
we can always find correlations
and the the goal is to move from things
that merely correlate to things that
have explanatory and predictive value so
that we can say okay oh yeah that makes
sense why that kind of pattern of brain
activity goes along with that kind of
conscious experience
and to make that link that to go from it
just does to oh it makes sense that it
does we need theories we need theories
that try to explain
um why conscious experiences have the
character that that they do and there
are a number of theories on offer the
one I prefer and the one I work with
mainly is the idea that the brain is a
kind of prediction machine and that
different kinds of conscious experience
are different kinds of brain based
prediction and that gives it a language
for connecting these two different
levels
why is being ourselves and having a
sense of self related to a discussion of
Consciousness how did those two things
get related do we know what it's like to
have this phenomenological experience of
being yourself we talk about it the book
is called being you like it's it's
what's that got to do with Consciousness
why is the self-rooted in Consciousness
and how do they relate
I think it's Central and I think this is
actually one of the side benefits if you
or maybe it's even the main benefit of
the real problem of Consciousness
approach because even if we don't solve
the whole mystery
it changes the way we think about the
problem and in science and philosophy
often when you change the way you think
about the problem you change the
questions that's also progress
and so when it comes to the self
we might think that the problem of
Consciousness is really the problem of
how we experience the world around us
there's a world around us it has objects
in it has people in it and we experience
them as moving around having different
visual appearances and so on
but
I think for many of us
there is a sense of mystery about what
the self is and we might take it for
granted and just think well there's this
essence of me you might want to call it
a soul or a spirit or something there's
this essence of me that is inside my
skull that is just there and it's the
thing that does the perceiving and it's
making the decisions about what my
organism body does and that's all there
is to it I mean that's separate from the
problem I think it's the central part of
the problem Consciousness for each of us
consistent experiences of the world but
also experiences of the self of being
the individual that we are
and if I think back in in talking to a
lot of people actually that's where the
relevance of Consciousness research
often becomes most clear so I think most
of us at one point or another in our
lives have wondered who am I really why
am I me and not someone else where was I
before I was born what will happen after
I die am I the same person from one year
to the next these are very personal
questions and so when we take the self
to be not
the thing that does the perceiving but
an aspect of this flow of conscious
experience that requires explanation
itself then I think we're making
progress
yeah I think when we're talking about
Consciousness the for the
non-neuroscientists amongst us it's the
most front and center part of it right
everybody understands what it's like to
have a felt sense of existing I know
what it's like they go through these
things
I mean they know what it's like almost
to the extent that you don't even think
about it because your yourself is kind
of always there you know your conscious
perceptions of the world change as you
move around
and you might have different emotions of
course and your experience of self does
change
but it's it's with you because it is you
so that might make it easy to overlook
when you think about the problem what is
the cell is it a a perception that we
have of the the thing that inhabits all
of the different experiences we go
through like what does it mean to say
that we are the same person now as we
were 20 years ago
that's a very complicated question
because I think it makes sense in some
ways but not in other ways and the
reason for that is that what it is to be
yourself is not one thing and the self
is not a thing it's a process it's a
unfolding process
that encompasses different kinds of
perceptual experience
one way to think of the nature of the
self for adult human being is to break
it down into different levels so at the
lowest level as you said a minute ago
there's this basic almost unquestionable
experience of just being a living
organism of merely existing on top of
that we have emotions and moods these
are key parts of what it is to be
yourself now an emotion is not a
perception of something out there in the
world it feels within it feels Part of
Me Part of us
and then there's an experience of the
body as an object again very easy to
take for granted
but when you think about it we
experience
our bodies as separate from the rest of
the world and there are many conditions
where this isn't the case people with
Phantom limbs people with other kinds of
conditions where their brains create
other experiences about what is or what
is not the body and then built on top of
that you have experiences of perceiving
the world from a first-person
perspective that's part of the self
experiences of agency and and the and
what we would call free will
which is not what most people think it
is but it's still part of the self in
terms of the experience of Free Will and
only then do you get to the the level of
personal identity the level of the self
where you'd associate a name a set of
memories of the past and plans for the
future and a social network a social
influence on Who We Are
so they're all these different
dimensions of Salford that are bound
together for most of us most of the time
in a seamless whole but we know from lab
experiments from neurology from
Psychiatry that they can and do come
apart
so the self is is complex it doesn't
have to be the way it is and when we ask
am I the same person I was 20 years ago
or will be in 20 years time in some ways
yes some of these aspects of self might
be quite similar but Others May well
change
and we won't notice the change
necessarily unless we have a sudden
illness or something like that then
we'll notice because it's very abrupt
but most of the time the self changes
slowly and smoothly and continuously and
so we are the same person but what that
person is is itself changing
yeah there's a sort of strange ship of
Theseus thing going on I think every
cell in your body has changed is it
seven years something like that I
remember hearing uh it was a piece of
breakup advice for girls uh that said no
matter how bad it hurts don't worry
because in seven years time there won't
even be a cell left in your body that
was around when you're in a relationship
with your ex which I always thought was
kind of a funny way of thinking about it
but even with that right so that there
is there is a person that is you and
there are cells that made up you but you
are more than just the cells because the
cells can be replaced and yet your sense
of self continues
that's exactly right and I think it
would be it's kind of strange to locate
the self in a particular cell or
collection of cells but it's equally
strange to not do that right because
then what is going on
then where is it it's in the
organization and in the process and this
this happens in other things as well
right I mean you have maybe a wetter
system and all the different molecules
of water probably change over time as
well and yet the storm system continues
to have a coherent identity
of itself and the same thing I think is
is here it's it's another version of the
the ship of Theseus argument by the way
that's that's the old kind of Greek
story isn't it where you have a ship and
you basically replace every part of the
ship with a new piece of wood here a new
piece of wood there a new rope here and
when you've replaced every single part
of it the question is is it still the
same or triggers broom if you're
British and grew up in the 90s
no you're shaming me now I grew up in
well maybe I'm too old Only Fools and
Horses you watched Only Fools and Horses
surely with my tiny Fools and Horses
yeah come on oh should we get sorry yeah
yeah I'm with you triggers broom the
famous example for the Americans
listening there's this guy who's kind of
an idiot that was a friend of all of the
other people on this comedy show and he
said that he was given an award by the
local Council for having used the same
broom for eight years and he couldn't
believe it and they said hey Amanda with
the same broom for eight years it's
amazing he said yeah it's only had four
new handles and three new heads and
everybody looked at him so yeah triggers
broom is the British ship of Theseus and
that's why British comedy is so good
because it's a philosophy lesson as well
as comedy yeah
um so yeah you know this this same sense
of self yeah is it is it the cells is it
the fact that you can just replace this
is it the organization of the cells but
even if it is does that mean that if I
was able to recreate that organization
elsewhere that that other me would be me
well it's no is it okay so is it the
fact that I as me inhabited this
particular
location these particular coordinates
and have these particular experiences
that I related to with all of my other
experiences contiguously over time well
maybe but what about if you're
unconscious what about if you're going
to general anesthetic what about when
you're asleep
right so they're they're all kinds of
weird thought experiments one can play
about the self and things that one can
do in practice like like anesthesia you
know on the first one if you recreate
all the parts somewhere else that then
what happens there's a very famous
philosophical thought experiment which I
do talk about a bit in the book called
the Teddy Transportation sort of
experiment and this is the idea that uh
you know a future or maybe even present
Elon Musk in his next business venture
develops this trans tele transportation
system where you go in it scans you at
whatever level of detail you think is
relevant now maybe the neurons maybe
every single molecule maybe every every
single atom or quark and it recreates an
identical and materially identical
version of you somewhere else let's say
on Mars
and the question is okay so this happens
what happens to you subjectively I mean
you're you're in let's say I don't know
where it is London you get in the device
and then
you are rebuilt in Mars but at the same
time that you're rebuilt in Mars you are
destroyed in London like a whole bunch
of lasers come and evaporate you because
we don't want an ex continual explosion
of people that has to work that way so
you
going into this transportation system
should probably just experience yourself
one instant you're in London the next
instant you're in Mars or on Mars
and then one day there's a mistake the
system goes wrong and the automatic
lasers which would have evaporated the
London you don't work and you're still
there in London and a technician comes
in holding a gun and says I'm sorry
we've got to do it the old style way
um but the lasers didn't work and then
suddenly you have this but hold on a
minute I'm still here so what is going
on the the Temptation is to think you're
either in London or on Mars but really
you're probably in both places and this
this highlights another assumption that
we might make which is another pop
culture reference like Highlander that
there can be only one
the idea of the self that is is
indivisible and unique and I think this
is probably wrong if you do
have exactly the same material thing
down to whatever level of organization
then you're gonna have the same
conscious experiences so in this case
initially there would be exactly two of
you one on Mars One in London but let's
assume they didn't pull the trigger and
you leave the the system and you go
wandering around of course from that
moment on
what it is to be each one of you
changes and you start to become
different people probably much like
identical twins start off very much
alike and then even though they're
surprisingly similar over the lifetime
they still diverge because they've had
different experiences their brains
change their cells change
well I don't think that even
interestingly in that thought experiment
no one would think
that the version of them that was
scanned and the version of them that
appeared in Mars even if they managed to
delete the old one and create the new
one at the same time I don't think
anybody listening would expect for their
felt sense to now be on Mars
I don't think that anybody would believe
that they their experience would can be
one contiguous stream and then they
would appear in Mars I think it would be
because then if that happened and they
didn't could it you would be split what
would happen you'd be experiencing two
lives at once like two eyeballs facing
in opposite directions I don't think
that that's true either I don't know
that would be a question you'd have to
there's a branch of philosophy called
experimental philosophy where instead of
making assumptions about what people
would think in these cases we you know
you tell them and then you ask them so
what do you think would happen I don't
know I mean I I think that if you
describe it sort of
properly then I think it wouldn't be
it's a bit like the other example that
you use when you go to sleep or go under
anesthesia
when you go under anesthesia you lose
Consciousness entirely and you'll move
from one room to another you usually
wake up in a recovery room which is
different from where the anesthetic was
administered
and most people expect to be the same
person
on the other side of that right and
they're not going from London to Mars
but they're going from one part of the
hospital to another yeah yeah so what's
the difference in that situation yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah why aren't you
waking up as a different person why when
you wake up in the morning do you expect
to behave the same way as you did
previously
yeah because I think the brain has a
very strong prior expectation
that we are the same person
and part of that is Justified because
not all of the molecules change
overnight and a lot of the you know the
processes that shape our conscious
experience and maintain an Integrity
maintain an identity like the storm
system maintains its identity over time
as well but we're not exactly the same
people before or after sleep or before
or after anesthesia
and I think that's fine and I think
recognizing and reconciling ourselves to
the ever-changing self is is actually
both scientifically and philosophically
accurate but also quite helpful and of
course echoes
a lot of what people have been saying in
in things like Buddhist literature and
meditative practice forever that there's
an impermanence to things and there's an
impermanence to the self and to Identity
and we should not try and fight against
that impermanence
will you say that it might be comforting
it may have also spiraled somebody into
this sort of recursive self uh skeptical
thought Loop uh that means they're now
not going to be able to leave bad for a
little while so I apologize if that's
happened so moving on to how we and our
Consciousness relates with reality you
say that our experience of reality is
that of a controlled hallucination what
do you mean by that
no metaphor is perfect but what I mean
by this is that our experiences of the
world and of the self too but let's stay
with the world for now
are not direct reflections of some
objective reality
like as if the world was just there and
it poured itself directly into our minds
through our eyes and our ears
it might seem like that and we open our
eyes in the morning or after anesthesia
and it just seems as though the world is
there and it has all these properties
like color and shape and size and sound
and our brains don't seem to have much
to do with it but our brains have
everything to do with it
and the idea and it's not a new idea is
that instead of our perceptual conscious
experience of the world being a process
of reading the world out in this kind of
outside in Direction
it's a process of active interpretation
in which the brain is always
trying to make its best guess about
what's out there in the world on the
basis of sensory information that comes
in through the senses but is ambiguous
and noisy and it doesn't have labels on
like it doesn't have a label saying I'm
from a red thing or I'm from a car it's
just electrical activity and the brain
has to make sense of it and the theory
the idea is that it does so by
basically having an internal model of
the most likely causes of the sensory
signals that it gets and what we
experience is not a readout of the
sensory signal but the brain's
predictions about what causes those
signals and this is a pretty big flip in
how we relate to our experiences because
even though it seems they come from the
outside in they're actually I think
coming from the inside out and the
sensory signals
are there to keep our brains predictions
our brains best guesses tied to reality
in ways that are useful for our Behavior
as a complex organism that's where the
metaphor of controlled hallucination
comes from hallucination because
experiences are internally generated
when we think about hallucinations in
everyday language we typically think
about
something that's generated internally
rather than something that's registering
the outside world but critically the
control is just as important in normal
everyday perception
uh perceptual experiences don't just
wander off into whatever they might be
they they're very carefully regulated
controlled by the world and the body and
that's why perception of course works
that's why Evolution has developed it
that way so that it's useful for us yeah
talk to me about how an evolutionary or
a sort of an ancestrally Adaptive lens
plays a role here why is it that we
would have evolved this particular type
of ability why is it that we would be
making these predictions what what
advantage does it give us and how does
that work
I think it makes things a lot easier for
complex organisms it has to maybe
especially so for complex creatures like
us
um
if there were a one-to-one
correspondence between some sort of
sensory information and something in the
world and what we should do about it
then we might not need any complex
business of making predictions inside
our brains but things aren't like that
way back in philosophy Emanuel Kant
pointed out or made the argument that we
can never perceive the world as it
really is we only perceive an
interpretation as a I guess a
transformation of it through a sensory
Veil
and sensory information that we get is
not reliable it's noisy it's uncertain
it might come from different things it
changes according to the context
according to the environment according
to lighting conditions
and so to get a reliable indication of
what's going on in the world it's not
enough simply just to funnel sensory
information into the brain it has to be
interpreted
and mathematically there's a there's a
way in which one might do this like
optimally completely perfectly but this
turns out to not really be possible for
things to do in practice so this whole
process by which the brain makes a
prediction of what's out there and then
uses sensory information to update these
predictions that turns out to be a very
very good approximation for how any kind
of system would solve this problem of
figuring out what's there under
conditions of uncertainty why not just
absorb what's there I don't know if I'm
being thick here but why why not just
observe it the way that it is why do
this other thing well take color for
example take our experiences of color
now when we experience color this is a
useful thing for for brains to provide
our experience with right because colors
allow us to keep track of surfaces when
lighting conditions change they
highlight things we might miss like the
color of a ripe fruit in a tree very
very useful
but where are colors in the world colors
don't exist out there in objective
reality anyway there's just
electromagnetic radiation that goes from
radio waves to gamma waves and our eyes
are only sensitive to three wavelengths
of that radiation and out of those three
wavelengths we experience millions of
colors so when we experience color we're
experiencing simultaneously
less than what's there because it's just
three wavelengths out of a long vast
spectrum and more than because we
experience of millions of colors not
just three
so in this case it wouldn't really be
very useful to for us to experience
what's really there because what would
that mean would it mean that we
experienced a continuous kind of set of
wavelengths from kilometer long to
whatever x-ray however long those are
it's not even clear what that would mean
to experience that and
yet we don't even experience a small
subset of that we create the brain
create something out of the sensory
environment that is very useful for us
but you can put it even more simply like
what's really out there is it objects or
is it atoms or is it quantum foam or
something nobody really knows what's out
there anyway
so to put as a benchmark experiencing
things as they really are
is I think just to misunderstand what
kind of business a brain is in just it's
in the business of helping us stay alive
this doesn't feel is it Donald Hoffman
is that the guy that's got the kind of
ideas that the world is very different
out there this doesn't feel a million
miles away from what he talks about
it is similar in some ways so yeah Don
Hoffman has his idea of an interface
theory of perception which is that what
we experience is some kind of user
interface
which in which intervenes between how
the world really is and something that's
useful for us to to survive by
we agree in the sense that the contents
of experience
are indirectly related to what's going
on out there in the world
but there are two places where we
disagree one is this metaphor of a user
interface I think is problematic because
it suggests that there's some kind of
Mini-Me inside my head you know looking
at this interface as much as I might
look at a computer screen and clicking
on this icon or that icon whereas back
to the self I think the self is part of
the interface there is no me that's
separate from the flow of experience and
I think things that that bring back that
smuggle back in this inner homunculus uh
is not the way to go and then we also
disagree and this is something that I've
talked to a few times about he then also
makes a whole bunch of claims about the
real nature of what's out there in terms
of little conscious agents everywhere
and and I've not yet been persuaded by
his ideas on that they might be in the
future but I haven't been yet and you
don't have to go that far you can still
just try to understand the nature of
perception as solving this indirect
thickness between how things are in the
world and what's the best way for the
brain to make sense of things in order
to survive
I remember reading uh an explanation for
an Adaptive uh justification for
Consciousness and included in that was
the fact that as complex social beings
who have to manage our own uh
interpretation our own status who have
to be able to model that of other people
and how that other person is interacting
with that other person and so on and so
on and so on and so on
how important do you think the complex
social networks of ancestral humans has
been to encouraging this predictive
sense that Consciousness sort of has
I think it's important but I think it's
important can be and sometimes has been
taken too far so we think about what it
means to be an adult human self we often
put a great deal of emphasis on the the
level of personal identity you know the
me being Anil Seth you being Chris
Williamson we have these we have these
identities in particular people and at
the level of personal identity the
social aspects is very important we have
to differentiate ourselves from others
and we have to at the same time predict
the behavior of others too so modeling
the minds of others is is absolutely key
to our actual everyday Behavior
and it may even be key to some aspects
of what it means to be yourself so it
could be as some people have argued one
of one uh one of my mentors Chris frith
has made this case that the reason we
know about our own mental States like
you know when I have an experience I
don't just have it I know that I have it
I can talk about it the reason I have
this insight into my own mental States
is because my brain first evolved the
ability to predict others mental States
and it's that kind of theory of mind
that then wrapped itself back into
within the organism
and gave each individual a more
elaborated sense of self I think that
might be the case
but I think you can go too far and say
as some do as well that that's necessary
for any kind of Consciousness that
that's why we have conscious experiences
and that's why we have selves
for me I actually go right the other way
and I say the origin of the predictive
brain the reason we have predictive
brains
is fundamentally because of the brain's
need to control and regulate the body
if you think about what brains are
generally for
not only in humans but in other animals
as well the primary duty of any brain is
to keep itself and the body alive
and the best way to regulate the body
is to be able to predict what's going to
happen to it prediction is that any
control engineer will tell you when you
can
have a predictive model of a system you
can much better control it because you
can stop it going wrong before it even
starts to go wrong like if you had a if
you had a central heating system or an
air conditioning system that predicted
the change in the outside weather you
could keep the temperature of your house
much more stable rather than just
reacting to changes as they happen
so for me that is the fundamental reason
why brains evolved this ability to make
predictions about sensory signals and
everything else gets built on that our
ability then to predict what the body is
like to to make perceptual predictions
about what's out there in the world I
think it's plausible all this Machinery
rests on this fundamental imperative to
stay alive
eventually social predictions become
important as well
but if you want to figure out what's
fundamental I don't think we look there
that's very interesting it's very
interesting to think that it
it's not necessarily what what's
important what you've done a ton of
experiments
that kind of show how the predictive as
opposed to the perceptual side of the
brain can cause people to erroneously
predict I guess could you explain some
of your favorite uh examples of that so
there's there's another this is one of
the fun things about this kind of job is
that the experiments can be quite
Illuminating but also entertaining and
this idea that what we perceive is a
kind of controlled hallucination
begs the question if we change things
can we change people's experiences in
ways that would be aligned with this
idea we've done this in a few different
ways so in one experiment we wanted to
simulate what it would be like when
people's brains had overly strong
perceptual predictions
so the control hallucinations become a
little less controlled you know more
little hallucination
and
sorry let me say that again because I'm
a little bit so
we wanted to
try and understand what would happen if
people's brains had overly strong
perceptual predictions so a little more
hallucination a little less control in
the controlled hallucination
and we did this by using a neural
network the sort of thing that's pretty
old hat now given the developments in AI
but a powerful neural network that's
able to classify what objects appear in
different images and we ran it backwards
using an algorithm that was adapted from
what Google called Deep dream we ran it
backwards so basically it just takes a
category of object like dog and IT
projects that back through the image to
simulate the kind of hallucination of
dog
and we did this with a 360 degree
panoramic video of Sussex University and
then we gave people headsets virtual
reality headsets to wear and replayed
the video so they could look around in
all directions and see what was going on
and the result is kind of striking it's
a really immersive experience and it's a
it's a model
not of what people do or how they behave
but it's a model of a different kind of
conscious experience
and the initial experiment was just a
proof of concept it wasn't really like
any specific experience people said it
was a bit like psychedelics but I didn't
think it was
and now what we're doing is making it
much more specific so we're taking this
proof of principle
and we're developing it so that we can
model different kinds of visual
hallucination so people that have
Parkinson's disease have hallucinations
of a specific kind people who have
visual loss have hallucinations of
another specific kind and we can now
begin to understand these differences in
terms of different ways the predictive
brain can go wrong
and by doing this
we can understand much more about how
the predictive brain works in the normal
case again there's a lesson from
engineering here that if you want to
understand how a system works you kind
of look at how it breaks in various ways
and that gives you a clue about what's
going on in the normal case which you
might otherwise miss things that you
would take for granted so that's kind of
a cool I'm enjoying this experiment
because it involves just modeling weird
kinds of experiences and then going out
and testing whether they accurately
reflect what people in the world with
these different kinds of hallucinations
really experience
we've also seen other sort of
experiments where people have had their
is it corpus callosum severed and then
you can do all manner of strange things
with different hands right hand being
related to the left hemisphere and left
hand being related to the right
hemisphere you can do things where you
show images to different sides and
people have to put their hand into bags
and select certain things out how much
is that related to this discussion of
Consciousness and how much is that just
uh I guess an artifact of the fact that
we've got this crisscross brain Body
Connection I think it's very related and
it's it's still absolutely fascinating
area there was a lot most of this work
was done quite a while ago because back
in the 50s 60s 70s when people had
really severe epilepsy there weren't
that many options to treat it and one of
the options quite a radical option was
this kind of surgery it's called a
calisotomy and it is basically cutting
this big bundle of connections that
connect the two brain hemispheres
it sounds incredibly brutal but the
surprising thing is that if you do it
seems to have surprisingly little
effects you know people they're pretty
much the same
and you can only find differences in
these quite weird situations where you
show different information to the
different hemispheres
and then all of a sudden it seems like
something strange is going on and it's
very relevant to Consciousness because
it immediately raises the prospect that
are there now two conscious selves
sharing a single brain that's kind of
weird
and
it's still a little bit unresolved in
these days
one of the side effects of better
Medical Treatments repcolepsy is that
these operations aren't done so much
and if they are done they're not done
where you separate all of the
hemispheres you usually leave some some
bits intact now this is great medically
but it's it's kind of deprived as this
wonderful
strange
um almost living thought experiments of
a split brain
and the story as it is now have a
colleague a former postdoc of mine in
Amsterdam yay Pinto who sort of picked
up the Chase and tried to try to do a
lot of these experiments have been done
in the 60s and 70s again it's like a
classic experiment as you say would be
um you'd give you'd show a picture which
one brain hemisphere would see
and
um it would you'd ask it to draw what it
saw
and then you'd ask the person
what why they drew what they drew but
having shown that hemisphere another
word
and so what's it's a it's a bit hard to
explain but basically one hemisphere is
usually where the neural circuitry for
language resides usually the left
hemisphere in most most adult humans
and so the left hemisphere
which sees the right visual field
can describe what it sees
but the left visual field which goes to
the right hemisphere
doesn't usually involve language it can
but it can sort of do other things it
can draw you know with the left hand
knacks everything is crossed in the
brain so it left goes to right right
goes to left and when you introduce a
conflict then the the left hemisphere
which can speak will often just make
something up to explain what the right
is doing it will confabulate but it will
be completely weird and wrong and you
have this uncanny sense that the left
hemisphere is is just unaware of what
the other half of its of the brain is
doing
now these days it seems to be a little
more finesse than that these massive
separations they may be not quite so
dramatic they might resolve over time
but there are still differences there's
definitely differences in in how people
with split brain
um operations how they can integrate
information across the whole visual
field and there is still this
fundamental question about the unity of
Consciousness can it be divided and what
does that what does that even mean I
find that it's probably not resolvable
but it's it it just it provokes our
assumptions about
what we are I mean again we have this
this idea just like the teddy
Transportation experiment that we are
one thing and unique and indivisible but
they're all sorts of ways that the self
can come apart and this is just one of
them a lot people have uh areas of the
brain that are removed or damaged for a
variety of reasons and you know
Consciousness persists perhaps their
personality changes so
Consciousness is it suggests at least in
part distributed in some regard it can't
it can't be necessary for every single
bit of the brain to be operating the way
it is for Consciousness to persist maybe
maybe that person person is somehow less
conscious if they were to lose five
percent of their brain because a railway
sleeper or whatever Railway
screw goes through the top of the head
or whatever that famous story is but it
does it make sense to ask the question
where does Consciousness arise is is
that even a a question that makes sense
it makes some sense like all these
questions it doesn't make sense if
you're looking for one place you know
the seat of the soul I don't think it
makes sense
that way but one of the
most uh I think most informative aspects
of the Neuroscience of Consciousness in
the last 20 years has been to try and
identify those parts of the brain that
are more involved in Consciousness
compared to those that aren't and it
will change it changes depending on how
you look
but there are some things which are
relatively clear
one of the things I find always a bit
surprising
is that three quarters of your brain if
you count it by number of neurons number
of brain cells three quarters of your
brain does not seem to be much involved
in Consciousness at all this is the the
cerebellum so our brains are organized
into these two hemispheres but we also
have this kind of mini brain at the back
cauliflower shape thing
called the cerebellum it is
very important in controlling how we
move and maybe even in orchestrating how
we think the ability to do things in
sequence and so on
but it doesn't really seem particularly
implicated
in Consciousness there are some people
born without a cerebellum that seems
absolutely fine all the
brain activity that we when we contrast
things like what happens when somebody
loses Consciousness or when they're
conscious of something and versus not
it never really involves the cerebellum
so the mechanisms that are most relevant
for consciousness
are elsewhere and they seem to be in the
cortex
maybe underneath the cortex so in the
more in the more frontal parts of the
brain compared to the cerebellum
and here is still just a big open
question
there are some experiments and some
theories
and here I must be I must admit it feels
a little a little depressing that after
this long and you know the advanced
technology that we've got and so on one
of the main debates in the field is
still about whether Consciousness is
more in the front of the brain or more
in the back of the brain
I mean great but it's it's a bit it's a
bit blunt isn't it I mean that's that's
quite a big contrast and it's still
unresolved and part of the reason it's
unresolved is there's one extremely
tricky problem with studying
Consciousness which is that we only know
what people are conscious of
if they tell us in some way whether
through words or through pressing a
button or through some other way of
reporting what they're conscious of
and the challenge here when we look at
what's happening in the brain is how do
we separate
what's happening in the brain that
actually underlies what we're conscious
of at any moment
and what is just necessary for us to
talk about it to report it
and it could be that the experiments
that say the front of the brain is
critical
well they show that but actually what
they're showing is that the front of the
brain mechanisms are important for our
ability to say what we're conscious of
but not for the conscious experience
itself
so the last few years in this field a
lot of it's been about trying to get
around that whether it's through Theory
or through clever experimental design
it's a real challenge but it's an
exciting challenge because you know I
think it's overcomeable it's just not
simple yeah I guess it's almost like
that section of the brain is a little
bit more of the philosophical zombie it
is the one that is able to explain it
but less so the one that is actually the
experiencer of it
that that that's a very nice way to put
it that may be the case but then there
are other people who say no actually
those are the same things it's kind of
the ability to explain what's going on
in another part of the brain that is the
experience so there are various theories
like there's a theory called higher
order thought Theory which basically
says that that Consciousness is in the
act of one part of the brain explaining
or looking at another part of the brain
but then other theories would be the
other way around so given that it seems
like there's varying parts of the brain
that are involved in varying degrees to
our experience of Consciousness and
there are chunks of it that are the
latest in terms of our Evolution to
develop that seem to be a little bit
more uh advanced is it right to say that
lower order animals in that case aren't
conscious have you got any idea whether
or not other animals are conscious do
they meet a threshold or a test by which
you would be happy to say that they are
it's so interesting you mentioned test
and one of the active projects I'm
involved in right now is what do we even
mean by a test for Consciousness and how
what would we want from one and how
might we develop it because it's not
just in non-human animals it's also in
brain damaged people it's in newborn
infants and it's of course in new
technologies like Ai and also neural
organoids which are collections of brain
cells grown in the lab there's lots of
lots of areas where we might want to
test for Consciousness because
well firstly for moral and ethical
reasons as soon as something is
conscious it has some sort of moral
status unethical status
for non-human animals
I personally think it's very hard to
know for sure but this is part of the
problem we can't ask them
but if we look at the preponderance of
evidence in terms of what brain
mechanisms are shared
with other species that we know or have
good reason to believe are important in
human consciousness then I think
it's fairly clear that all mammals have
some kind of conscious experience even
if they can't tell us about their
conscious experiences they share the
same parts of Cortex and the bits
underneath the cortex the thalamus that
that just are very deeply implicated in
human consciousness when you get Beyond
mammals it becomes
harder because we don't have a consensus
Theory Of Consciousness that we can
generalize
to to other things very easily it's
going to be a kind of what's our best
guess you know what what's the best
thing we can say with the limited
evidence that that we have
and here it depends on
what kind of
theory about the most important aspects
of Consciousness if you think as we said
earlier like if you think
having a sense of theory of mind and
being able to predict what other people
other animals are going to do is
important maybe it's quite restricted if
you think Consciousness is co-extansive
with something like intelligence or
social intelligence then maybe it's not
present in that many other species my
dog doesn't know whether I'm going to go
left or right or whether it's whatever
time or this other time but it might
even you might some people might even
make a stronger claim that because your
your dog can't do that it's not
conscious at all
precisely yeah yeah I think I think this
is I I find this unappealing and not
just unappealing because I like to think
dogs are conscious but I find it
theoretically unappealing because I
think that the roots of conscious
experience
are in
the the need for brains to regulate the
body to keep the body going in
environments where there's a lot of
information in their sensory world
that pertains to how the brain regulates
the body
so if you think Consciousness is more
rooted in this this fundamental process
of
physiological regulation then you're
going to be more liberal about
how many other creatures have it and you
might start to think okay you know it's
not just mammals it's it's it's maybe
Birds it's maybe cephalopods like
octopuses and Squid I'm down for I'm
down for octopi I'm down for octopi
being conscious man I've read enough
sci-fi stories about super intelligent
octopi
um
what is the
most commonly used definition of
Consciousness that is the barometer that
most researchers in this field are using
to work out whether a threshold is being
crossed or not
so the definition doesn't really provide
a threshold which is part of the problem
I mean the definition that most people
use people use different definitions but
fairly good one comes from the
philosopher Thomas Nagel who says for a
conscious creature there is something it
is like to be that creature it feels
like something to be me it feels like
something to be
um a dog but it doesn't feel like
anything to be a table or a chair
it's what makes a conscious creature
more than just an object
that's the intuitive definition that of
course is just a description it doesn't
give you
something that you can then go and
measure
and
the the consensus about what to do in
that what to actually go out and measure
well there is no consensus it's a very
febrile area of discussion and and it
depends what kind of Consciousness
people are looking for so a a well used
test in the sense of that's been used a
bunch of times is the mirror
self-recognition test
so the mirror self recognition test asks
whether an animal
knows in some sense that its mirror
image is itself rather than another
animal we humans we do this naturally we
look in the mirror and For Better or
Worse we know that it's us but this
ability in humans doesn't
appear at Birth it takes several months
it takes probably over a year to develop
in in human infants
what does this mean
it means that it takes a while for that
aspect of self-consciousness to develop
it does not mean that Consciousness was
entirely absent before then it just
means the aspect of perceiving oneself
as a distinct entity that might take
quite a while and may be restricted to a
few species rather than loads of species
at the other end you might say something
about responsiveness to pain and here I
have a lot more sympathy so you can look
at what animals will do
when they are subjected to some
something damaging or painful and not
just do they run away but do they do the
kind of constellation of behaviors that
we associate with our conscious response
to pain do we tend the wound do we go to
somewhere where there's anesthetic
available
um
do we change our whole organization of
our Behavior so as to Aid recovery
I think this
is I think it's the most sensible place
to look it might it might be a bit you
know you have to pick where on the scale
you want to you want to make do you want
to be overly conservative or overly
liberal because you're not going to get
it bang on
so in in my you know my feeling
pain is important if if a species if a
creature has the ability to suffer and
then it's really deserving of a place in
this sort of charm circle of ethical
moral consideration yeah I was thinking
about a snake and uh something tells me
that a snake can't reflect I can't uh
recognize itself in a mirror but if you
stick a stapler into the side of it it's
it's probably gonna know
it's gonna know for sure yeah yeah I
don't know I mean I have actually no
idea whether anyone's done the mirror
self recognition test on a on a snake I
mean this is also
part of the problem these experiments
are quite hard to do and we've only
studied a handful of species with
anything that's hard to do and I'll get
get a snake get a mirror stick it stick
it on the floor you know what I mean
well you know you say not hard to do but
you get you know you have to do it
several times and also there's many
reasons why animals fail this test like
um
many animals don't like to make eye
contact
and some don't like mirrors so they're
just going to fail this test for reasons
for other reasons so even then you don't
know how to interpret the results I was
thinking as you were explaining the
mirror self recognition test I was
thinking about uh bats or voles that
have got particularly poor eyesight
basically no eyesight or what about an
animal who's had both of its eyes
damaged yeah if it's never able to
detect itself does that mean that it's
no longer conscious again like yeah
probably not right I mean that that was
Thomas Nagel's point in his his paper
where we where the definition of
Consciousness came from that we we've
been talking about his paper was what is
it like to be a bat
and it's a very interesting thought to
experiment because bats of course have
echolocation we don't have anything like
echolocation
um so it will be impossible for us to
experience
being a bat unless you actually are a
bat with the potential exception of not
Batman but there's this there's a few
people who have developed so-called
human echolocation so people who've gone
blind or who are born blind
and have developed the ability to make
clicking sounds
and perceive
the layout of their environment through
processing The Echoes to these clicking
sounds I find this really really
interesting it's it's you know we our
brains didn't evolve to do this so it's
not going to be as good as a bat's not
as good as a bat
but it's it's the closest that we might
be able to get
the weirdest first date that I ever went
on was it I think it's called Cafe Noir
in London have you heard of this is this
where they serve food in total darkness
correct and it's blind it's only blind
servers now I think that rather than
using echolocation the servers have just
memorized the rooms layout incredibly
well but you know
my bedroom I tried to go to the bathroom
last night without turning the light on
so it wouldn't ruin my sleep and I
crashed into something I've been in that
room you know hundreds of times so there
is some part of their spatial awareness
their proprioception which has been
tuned up for them to be able to carry
plates through a room with tons of
people in all talking and not drop it on
the wrong person remember where they're
going find the person of where they're
going etc etc
um but yet that was that was the first
day I don't know what it says that this
girl decided to take me into a room
where she literally couldn't see me
um I'm not really too sure what that
says about our first date but it was
really fun actually and I remember
thinking at the time there's something
going on here there is something that
has happened to allow these people to
compensate for
yeah it's fascinating and the thing is I
know your example of you kind of stumble
around in the darkness trying to find a
bathroom but you know if you if you
adapted to it if you gave yourself time
and you can do surprisingly well at
picking up just these very subtle cues
out there and if you think about these
waiters in Cafe Noir
imagine like how much better you get at
moving around in the dark after just
trying to do it for an hour and then
just imagine that they've done it for a
lifetime maybe it's not so surprising
that they're that they're really good
but about the the mirror thing I mean
it's true that we tend to overemphasize
or we tend to strongly emphasize visual
stuff as humans we we feel we're very
visual creatures and again that bias may
lead us astray when thinking about other
animals the mirror self-recognition test
seems to be a visual test but there are
some researchers
looking for instance
you know didn't even go to bats you go
to dogs dogs
uh they have vision of course but for
dogs smell olfaction is so much more
important so there are people trying to
develop an olfactory mirror test for for
a dog and I'm not don't ask me quite how
it works I have no idea exactly what
they do but I like the I like the point
that that if you you have to
you have to try and understand
the ecological niche or as the there's a
German philosopher psychologist called
Jacob Von erkskill he came up with his
concept of the unvelt the kind of lived
world of another animal so if you're a
bat you know your world is suffused by
by a co-locatory signal so you kind of
would have a sense of where things are
and it wouldn't be visual but it would
be like having radar or something like
that and then bees have another unwelt
entirely where where the light reflected
from um in the UV or infrared becomes
very prominent
and I think this is a there's a
wonderful book by by Ed young called an
immense World which which really
highlights that it seems as though we're
sharing the same world but if you if you
have you know a human a mouse a bat an
elephant all in the same space
and assume they're all conscious and ask
well if they are conscious what would
their experiences be like their
experiences are so different well I
suppose what's interesting about that
example of having a number of different
animals within the same environment and
then let's say that it's a maze or the
they they just need to go about and do
the normal thing they need to maybe find
some food and some water and do the rest
of it
from the outside you can observe
Behavior which looks like it could be
coming from the same place right because
the net outcome of their behavior is the
same it may do it in different ways but
the outcome is that they eventually find
some food and they find some water and
they go in shade when it's hot and they
go into sunlight when it's cold and blah
blah blah
but internally
how each of those animals arrives at the
thing that it's doing to track down the
food the human May heavily rely on its
visual field the dog may heavily rely on
its olfactory senses the mouse may use
if it was a bee the B would have
UltraViolets
um it can see ultraviolet light so okay
you're you're able to
produce Behavior which is not only
adaptive and useful but from the outside
might not look all that different
and yet the root at which each animal
got to it is completely different
well let's Linger on that for a second I
think there's there's something worth
unpacking here because in this example
of I don't know a mosquito an elephant a
human it sounds like a bad joke doesn't
it go into a bar and um they're all in
the same bar
and I think in this case the behaviors
are quite different like in a mosquito
will detect levels of carbon dioxide
and you know be able to use that to find
skin I think that's what they're
sensitive to I can't remember now but
they'll be sensitive to very different
kinds of things and and and we'll do
things that seem a bit uncanny like you
move around in the in the dark you know
mice was so sensitive in their hearing
and sense of vibration that they'd be
able to run away owls can hear things at
such a vast distance that it the
behaviors would be different and so it's
maybe
easy to recognize that the perceptual
world the unveiled of these creatures
would also be different to us I think
where we might make mistakes is actually
within a species
so if you have a bunch of people in this
room in a room
and they're all you interacting with
each other
then
you're right they may all do the same
sort of thing they may all look for food
they may all go from to the shade when
it's hot and so on
and just in general in our everyday
lives
we tend to expect people to behave in a
way that we might behave more or less
and so it's very easy then to assume
that other people
experience the world the same way we do
because their behaviors might be
relatively consistent
compared to you know the difference
between me and a mosquito
but I think this is a mistaken
assumption
it seems to us we see the world as it is
and we use the same words often to
describe things like I see a red car you
see a red car we both say it's a red car
and so we assume then
that we're having the same internal
experience of this shared objective
reality
and I don't think that's true in fact I
know it's not true in fact this is not a
new thing to say there's plenty of
evidence out there of people who
experience the world in very different
ways you know that have hallucinations
and so on have synesthesia when people
see colors when they hear sounds and
mixing of the senses and of course
there's the whole area of neurodiversity
which really highlights that there are
there are substantial differences in how
different people encounter a shared
world
but I think we still underestimate
what's going on because at the moment
unless
we are hallucinating or unless we
associate ourselves with a
neurodivergent condition like autism or
something like that it's easy to assume
that we're neurotypical and we
experience the world just as it is
and I don't think there is such a thing
I think that we all differ
and understanding that unpacking that I
think is a great challenge because we we
know the importance of
taking into account and actually
um
really relative relishing I'm trying to
think of the right the right word here
not just taking into account but
um
recognizing the value of diversity that
we can see on the outside you know
diversity and cultural background and in
in body shape size and so on but we also
have this inner diversity
and it's
if we don't recognize it that it's there
because we use the same words and it
seems as though we see things as they
are I think we're losing an opportunity
to
um
benefit from A diversity of ways of
perceiving of ways of seeing things
and this is a this is a sorry it's a
very long-winded way of mentioning that
we have a project at the moment called
the perception census which is trying to
do exactly this it's a big citizen
science project where we ask people to
join in and do a bunch of pretty simple
and fun little interactive visual
Illusions and so on to try and help us
get a picture of perceptual diversity to
map out this hidden landscape of of
inner variation and it's online it's all
you need is a computer and you're making
people go if they want to try this up if
they just um look for perception census
just type that into Google or go through
my website just look for anilseath.com
and take you straight there and you can
do a little bit you can set it aside
come back and we'll keep track of your
progress and you'll learn a lot about
perception and your own particular Way
of perceiving the World we've already
had about 26 000 people try it now and
from 100 countries so we want to make
this a real real Landmark study
both to map out this perceptual
diversity but also to raise awareness
that it's actually there and I think
that will be of quite some significant
social value talking about perception
what happens when you took LSD
quite a lot
I mean I didn't take LSD until I was in
my 40s I didn't
have the opportunity or probably the
desire when I was a teenager in South
Oxfordshire
and at some point it seemed like the
right thing to do I guess I really
wanted to know what it was like from the
first person
you know thinking about consciousness
a lot
for me it doesn't do this for every
researcher in this area but for me made
me very curious about
what kinds of conscious experiences are
available because part of the whole
motivation for me is understanding what
we take for granted in our own
experience because it's always been
there it's always been some particular
way and not another way
so ways to get out of the perceptual
habits that we're in I think can be very
Illuminating and there are many ways to
do this there's there's meditation
there's jumping out of a plane there's
all sorts of things right but
psychedelics is one obvious way and very
reliable it's very reliable and it's and
it's reliably substantial
you just know so well this is what I was
expecting this is what I'd been told and
in fact this is true right you you put
some you put a little tab on your tongue
and under your tongue and then stuff
will happen
and it will happen for a while and I
think I was
I was both reassured and surprised
and the way to explain that is
nothing happened that I didn't expect to
happen
but the fact that was happening to me
was still surprising
and what it involved was
large changes in my perceptual
environment you know things became much
more fluid
things became much more changeable there
seemed to be this influence that I could
have over what I was perceiving by
almost willing clouds to change into
things they did things started to bleed
together and things became imbued with
this sort of sense of quite
magic and they would there would be this
quality to the whole environment that
that changed and of course the sense of
self changed as well
and and it's very it's a notoriously
hard to describe these kinds of
experiences without sounding entirely
enough I think Michael Pollan has done a
good job in his book how to change your
mind well if Aldous Huxley you know if
we have to call on one of the greatest
wood Smiths of all time to try and tell
us what he thinks and does a perception
then yeah
yeah it's it's hard and I I don't want
to mangle these things and rather just
appeal to these kinds of authorities but
but it was it was
yeah I
I've been prepared to be disappointed I
think about okay it's it's well that
wasn't quite as transformational as I as
I'd been hoping for but it was I was not
I was not disappointed
and it is it is remarkable I think the
other thing that it's interesting that
for me it just reinforced the the idea
that I went in with that our conscious
experiences are biological phenomena
in the same way that anesthesia did you
know anesthesia for me shows that you
can if you change the brain in a very
specific way
you change Consciousness in a very
reliable predictable specific way as
well with anesthesia it goes away and
then comes back
with psychedelics again your your
intervening in the system in a very
precise and very specific way
and your conscious experience changes in
a very you know the details may vary but
the overall trajectory of what's
happening is very predictable yeah so
the implication here is that if
Consciousness wasn't something which is
as you had predicted
it shouldn't be able to be impeded or
imposed on by these sorts of substances
you shouldn't reliably be able to change
it because it should be something which
is outside of the the the the changeable
it's interesting because some people
would take entirely the opposite
conclusion and the fact that a
psychedelic experience may give you a
sense that you
you're outside of your body
or that yourself is part of the universe
may take these experiences at face value
and reach the conclusion that their
normal conscious experience is some kind
of heavily filtered down version of the
perturbed version of the molested
perverse version of what is true it
always it always happens to be that what
is true involves psychedelics you know
it's never what is true is your mind
when you're sat on the toilet like
that's it's never that state it's always
a state of sort of psychedelic Bliss
yeah and and that's I mean that's one
way you can go and you can say now I've
seen things as they really are the
blinkers are off the filters have been
have been removed
that for me is not an appealing way to
think about it
it is for me it is yeah you change your
brain you change your experience it's
exactly what you'd expect to happen
if our conscious experiences were
embodied biological phenomena
moving
Beyond just your research how has all of
the work that you've done into the
nature of self changed about how you
think about problems or deal with the
the challenges and the joys of Life have
you found that it's sort of impacted the
the way that you relate to emotions it's
one of the things we haven't necessarily
mentioned is emotions for all that they
may be this phenomenon that exists and
they're kind of that or or there and not
there at the same time they feel
incredibly real they feel like the most
real thing that you can think of you
know going through anxiety it's it's the
reason why uh the Greeks and the Romans
personified the gods right because it
felt like something it was such a
visceral experience that it could only
be bestowed On You by a higher power
that was cursing or blessing you
specifically and I'm interested in how
all of this time thinking about the
nature of self and Consciousness has
changed your relationship with your
enjoyable and unenjoyable experience of
it yeah emotions that they're definitely
real as our experiences and they're
probably the most important experiences
we have I mean they they're what matters
and they guide and direct our Behavior
every minute of every day
they're real in in the same way that
colors are real I think they don't exist
out there independently of a mind but
they are critical to our mental lives
in my work I think of that connection
even more
tightly so
an emotion for me is another kind of
perception it's a perception of the
state of the body
in the context in which we're in it's a
perceptual inference about what's
happening in the body
and so they're very tightly coupled and
thinking about this a lot it's always a
challenging question to try and
understand what its impact has been on
me personally partly because I don't
have a twin brother who went off to be
an estate agent to compare against
but I think it has had an effect
however unreliable that introspective
conclusion might be
and I mean I can kind of see it maybe
it's just getting older as well but I
can kind of
see that I'm a bit more adaptively
detached from the transient flow of
emotions than I was not entirely I mean
I'm not trying I'm not claiming to be
some sort of enlightened
um monk I mean I still feel frustrated
anxious sad upset furious at times happy
too sometimes now the the flow of
emotions is still there
but
I think it has helped me in the round to
navigate
things more effectively and of course
one the goal isn't to be uniformly happy
I don't think the goal is to just
be able to
um
accept
the stream of emotions and curate them a
little bit but to to live a life where
they're part of you and you don't try
and fight them quite so much
I think in one specific area I can see
progress so for a few times in my life I
did suffer depression I had it pretty
bad and and and when you were saying
that
the visceral reality of things like
anxiety I know this very well and these
were you know the hardest times in my
life
how to get out of those is you know it's
a great challenge everyone does it in
their own way but I think
ing about the impermanence the
constructed
provisional nature of the self and of
emotional responses
has helped me in this regard a bit it
provides a little bit of a psychological
immune system
it may be a bit similar to to meditation
now people who've done a ton of
meditation also learn to pay attention
to their emotions and their mental
States and to recognize that their
transient that they pass
I think the direct experience of
meditation is probably better than the
theoretical knowledge you know in the
same way that direct experience of
psychedelics
exceeds and outstrips what one might
learn from the books and from
experiments
but I think it can get you somewhere
and in a sense thinking about
Consciousness for now 20 25 30 years
that's been a lot of hours and so in a
way that's been a lot of some kind of
meditative practice on the nature of the
cell phone of perception and
I would be I'd be disappointed if it had
no effect I think it has had an effect
and I think it's had a beneficial effect
though you know there's still a lot of
work I'm still very much a work in
progress
and also ladies and gentlemen if people
want to keep up to date with the stuff
that you're doing online where should
they go
the easiest place go to my website it's
anilseath.com or you can follow me on
Twitter I still use Twitter Anil K Seth
and I really appreciate you I look
forward to seeing what you do next I've
been a fan of your work for a long time
so it's been very cool to catch up today
I'm so glad we were able to have this
conversation I know it took a long time
to arrange thanks so much Chris what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe